sir jeffrey john donaldson was
officially confirmed as the democratic
unionist party's latest leader this week
it's third in just two months in his
first speech as leader sir jeffrey
insisted the only path to stable and
sustainable government
includes the removal of the irish sea
border
and earth unity against the brexit deals
northern ireland protocol
which effectively imposed it but the
unity he seeks
seems some way off with the resignation
of a dup storm and assembly member
onto jeffrey's first day in charge
well in his first television interview
since becoming leader sir jeffrey
donaldson spoke to our senior island
correspondent
david blevins about how to tread the
tricky path ahead
and his concerns about rising tension on
the streets of northern ireland
sir jeffrey you have said the removal of
the protocol is the only path to stable
government in northern ireland
what if it isn't removed well at the
heart of the
belfast or good friday agreement um are
three sets of relationships and there's
a very delicate balance within that
agreement as to how
those relationships are managed and one
of the key relationships is that between
northern ireland and great britain and
the agreement is very clear
the principle of consent protects the
right of the people
of northern ireland to determine their
constitutional status
when you harm one of those relationships
you harm
all of them by extension and that's
exactly what we have seen happening
because our relationship with great
britain has been harmed by this protocol
so too our relationship with the
republic of ireland has been harmed and
indeed
it has undermined and destabilized
relationships
within northern itself and we've seen
that even on our streets so
it is imperative for all of us that we
resolve these issues i'm not
accepting that this can't be done i'm
not accepting
that there is no solution i believe
there is and that's what i'm going to
strive for
and i'm not going to contemplate failure
you talk about the tension
on the streets the dup says the
government
is aware and is listening to the
concerns but this is the same government
that promised your party there would
never be an irish sea
border so why should the loyalists who
are protesting trust this government
well i understand their skepticism i
really do
um we've heard the prime minister even
in recent weeks
talk about uh addressing the issues and
the problems created by the protocol
we've heard him recognize that there um
there are difficulties in terms of the
relationship between great britain
and northern ireland but not just in
trading terms the prime minister
also needs to recognize that this
impacts on our constitutional position
i'm prepared always to give people a
second chance and i'm prepared to give
the prime minister
an opportunity now to put right what was
done wrong
to northern ireland under the protocol
but there are those who would say
it's time for the dup to put right the
wrong
of promoting a brexit that was going to
require a border somewhere
is it perhaps time to look at the
positive to promote the benefits of
having
access to the eu market and the gb
market
i believe there are opportunities going
forward but
we can't get to those opportunities
because of these unnecessary barriers
much of our supply chain comes from
great britain
whether you are a consumer buying goods
in a supermarket
or a business relying on component parts
for your manufacturing process we need
to fix that supply chain problem
we need to restore northern ireland
place within the uk
both the market and constitutionally and
if we can do that
then yes we will see the opportunities
that will flow
provided we can find practical solutions
on trade with the eu
let's talk for a moment about legacy
we've seen another two
historical prosecutions collapse this
week
you're a former soldier so you will
understand the concerns of veterans
you're also a victim two of your cousins
were murdered during the troubles
how does northern ireland draw a line
under its difficult past
is there an alternative to the
government's proposal of a
prosecutorial amnesty uh i think we need
a
a process that moves us from where we
are uh to where we can finally say well
look
we've examined the past we have given
people the opportunity and to
explore whether there is the prospect of
prosecutions
against those who murdered their loved
ones and
and then yes we need to move to the next
phase of the peace process we need to
move our society
beyond an examination of the past to the
kind of reconciliation and healing
that we desire to see in northern
ireland so
we need some form of process that
recognizes the suffering
of many the injustice that many feel in
northern ireland i don't think you can
pull a veil over that i don't think you
can ignore that
i think that if we're going to have
healing we need to have recognition and
acknowledgement
you are the dups third leader in the
space of two months
is the party imploding because of what
some would consider to be an
own goal on brexit that resulted in a
protocol
and unsettled unionism about
power sharing and the prospects for
irish unity
i don't think it is to do with brexit um
i think that
the issues that have arisen within the
dep
have multiple causes my job now my
task is to bring the party together
again
and to together on our common ground
the dup believes passionately in the
union of great britain and northern
ireland we believe passionately
that northern ireland and all of its
people are best served
being part of that united kingdom we
need to broaden the appeal of unionism
and therefore we need to resolve our
internal difficulties i believe we're
well on our way now to doing that
the meeting of the party executive this
week
um saw unanimous support for my
leadership
it saw people coming together
acknowledging the hurt that had been
caused on both sides
of the argument and i think now we're
moving away from that and
and we've walked back from the idea of
factionalism
your deputy leader paula bradley this
week apologized
to the lgbtq plus community for what she
described as atrocious and hurtful
comments made by some elected
representatives from the party in the
past
do you share her regret about that and
how will you address any repeat of those
comments
well i think it is true and it's not
just in the case of the dup that things
have been said in the past that have
been hurtful to
people and i think it's right when that
happens that
we say sorry and acknowledge that hurt
equally i hope in time others will be
able to acknowledge that they have
caused hurt
uh for example to people from a strongly
held faith perspective
david the kind of northern ireland i
want is one where we can have respect
for difference
and in terms of looking ahead i hope
uh that my colleagues will recognize
that when when we
take decisions about social issues uh
when we speak
out on social issues which we are
entitled to do that we do so in a
gracious way
that we avoid language language that is
seen as intemperate
um or disrespectful but where that
happens i will not hesitate to
ensure that it doesn't happen again
thank you very much for your time